in the heart of Manhattan New York there
stands a building which conceals its
past this is 22 Vanderbilt a fairly
non-descript modern office tower that
houses various PR and Tech firms but
beneath this glass and granite facade
there lies another structure a relic of
a bygone era it is the iron skeleton of
the Biltmore Hotel New York once a
splendid and widely celebrated luxury
hotel that operated from 1913 until its
demise in 1981 when it turned into the
building we see today the hotel had
magnificent ballrooms and rooftop
gardens a Turkish bath and an elaborate
clock in the Palm Court which was famous
as a meeting place for everyone from
writers such as JD Salinger and F Scott
Fitzgerald to the countless young
students who frequented the hotel
Zelda and F Scott Fitzgerald were even
once kicked out of their hotel room
baths still running after their
honeymoon party became two riotous to
serving the other guests
reporter Christopher gray describes the
hotel saying the Biltmore and in
particular its clock became almost as
much an institution as Grand Central
itself and it is here in the grand
Cascades Ballroom one evening in May
1941 that we encounter a figure Central
to this story
it was the inaugural dinner of pen in
Exile a group of German writers who had
fled their Homeland to escape the
horrors of the second world war among
them was one of the most celebrated and
widely published authors of their time
Stefan Spike svike who was Jewish had
fled Vienna Austria just eight years
prior to this evening in May
of the authors spoke that night but
according to reports none so moved the
audience as the short speech given by
Stefan's feig he spoke of his shame and
sorrow for what was happening in Europe
he spoke of the Nazi Uprising as an
almost metaphysical threat not just to
himself and others but to his language
which as a writer he held very dear
George prochnick in this book The
Impossible Exile recounts part of his
speech we writers of the German language
feel a secret and tormenting shame
because these decrees of Oppression are
conceived and drafted in the German
language the same language in which we
write and think I feel it is my duty
publicly to ask forgiveness of each of
you for everything which today is
inflicted upon your peoples in the name
of the German spirit
50 years later the Biltmore Hotel New
York was replaced by the Bank of America
Plaza
to him who has often told the tales of
others many tales will be told sorry
our story continues here at six Rue
princess sashramon Paris this is the
former location of the Village Voice
Bookshop which closed on July 31st 2012.
the owner of the shop was odile Hali she
was the daughter of a French army
officer who escaped a German POW Camp to
join the resistance during the second
world war sometime before its closing
director Wes Anderson walked into this
very Wes Anderson looking book shop and
was introduced to Stefan zweig when he
picked up this book beware of pity and
started reading
to him that hath to him shall be given
these words from the scriptures the
writer May safely restate as to him that
has told much to him much shall be told
nothing is further from the truth than
the only two common notion that the
author's fantasy is incessantly at work
within him to the person who has over
and over again tried to trace human
Destinies many tell their own story plus
was so engrossed that he stood in the
Bookshop reading for 45 minutes before
he finally purchased the book and left
what so captured his attention was the
way svig framed the story as a series of
nesting encounters that ended with the
book's fictional author meeting a
character who told the author his life
story it was this framing device that
ended up becoming the inspiration for
the opening sequence of the Grand
Budapest Hotel it is an extremely common
mistake
people think the writer's imagination is
always at work that he's constantly
inventing an endless supply of incidents
and episodes
who wouldn't
at the creme Budapest
it's an institution The Grand Budapest
Hotel is West Anderson's eighth feature
film it's so far his most financially
successful and his most widely acclaimed
it won four Oscars and it felt like a
marked step forward in his already
iconic personal style there's so much I
could talk about with this film The
exacting Precision of the plot and its
Pace the way it seems to unfold like a
mechanical snow globe music box each
piece fitting together with the
confidence of a practice Storyteller
people have talked endlessly about the
beauty of its color palettes set design
and costume design and of course I could
talk about the many beautifully
constructed shots in the film or the
quality of performance from Ray fines as
Gustav h i myself love this movie I've
seen it countless times including the
director's commentary twice I've read
the screenplay and the companion book
put together by film critic Matt zoller
sites I could tell you the Easter eggs I
know that Willem dafoe's boots are
custom Prada I know that the size of the
boy with apple painting is different in
this scene than it is in this scene
because Wes Anderson thought it looked
better to have Saoirse Ronan carrying a
smaller painting I could point out how
the window in the prison cell is a
different shape in this shot than it is
in this shot I could tell you that
Harvey Keitel lived for a few days with
his cellmates in this prison cell in
preparation for their scenes I could
tell you that all the Monk's heads were
shaved in this scene despite the fact
that they all ended up covered I could
show you the image of the hotel that
inspired the Grand Budapest Hotel itself
that of Hotel pup and Carlo V very
Carlsbad from the Library of Congress
photochrome collection I could talk
about how I think this movie is at least
partially responsible for the
popularization of using multiple aspect
ratios as a storytelling technique which
when this movie came out with its four
aspect ratios wasn't that common but
which now is a fairly widely accepted
way of showing different periods of time
or different perspectives in both film
and television I've talked in the past
in another video about the extent to
which the movie draws on references to
other filmmakers and films quietly
presenting itself as a fairly thorough
Pastiche of films set in European hotels
there's so much beautiful detail and
Technical handiwork on the surface of
this film to admire that I think in many
ways the real heart of the film the
beauty that lies in a story that at
first seems equal parts distant and
Fantastical actually has a sort of
universal resonance I think the Grand
Budapest Hotel has been as successful as
it has been not just because of the
film's visual novelty but in fact
because of the depth and sincerity that
Lies Beneath the film's mendel's-esque
sugar coating
in the Wes Anderson collection book
about the film matsular sites describes
the film's emotion as something that
unfolds with multiple viewings and this
is something that I've found to be true
for myself as well on the first watch
it's very easy to be caught up in the
Pretty Lights of this madcap action
mystery Caper when the film's emotional
moments do come they are quick and
stabbing
in the end they shot him
and they are gone almost as quickly as
they arrive I wasn't moved by the movie
the first time I saw it and detractors
of Wes Anderson's work often find it
somewhat emotionally distant but as you
revisit the film I think it's underlying
Melancholy becomes more apparent when
you know zero and Agatha's story is
going to end like this Shia no infant
son would be killed two years later by
the Prussian greep and absurd little
disease the brief moments where older
zero talks about her earlier in the film
becomes more poignant when you know the
finality of Gustav's trajectory there's
a more apparent loneliness in his
character from the start the emotional
subtext is there it's just when you
don't know what you're looking for the
first time around it's easy to get lost
in all the
and of course this splicing of moments
of striking emotion into what feel like
otherwise unassuming quirky comedies or
Adventures has been part of Wes
Anderson's Mo from the beginning this
move is part of the Hidden beauty that
I'm talking about but it's not all of it
I think the real thing that makes the
Grand Budapest Hotel Wes Anderson's most
unique and successful film lies deeper
than that
as the film opens we see a young woman
who we never learn anything about but
what we do know is that she's been so
moved by the book she's reading that she
makes a pilgrimage to visit the statue
of an author I think what the Grand
Budapest Hotel is really about on its
deepest level can only really be
understood by understanding the life of
the author whose work the film is
inspired by Stefan's feig
one of the things we quickly find when
reading Stefan zweig's description of
his hometown Vienna in his Memoir the
world of yesterday is that his
description of the place has a similar
quality to the way the Grand Budapest
Hotel and the country of zubraka are
portrayed through the perspective of
Gustav H in the movie the movie's
Immaculate representation of the past
isn't just a fun novelty it also serves
the purpose of actually embodying the
Fantastical Nostalgia and almost
hopelessly rose-tinted image of the past
that both zweig and Gustav share for
spyg Vienna wasn't just ideal in its
aesthetic Beauty he describes a cultural
atmosphere of progressive optimism one
that appreciated arts and culture valued
Humanity tolerated differences and felt
secure and peaceful some of the stories
he tells of Vienna speak to this kind of
fanaticism of culture and art there was
a famous old theater that had held many
performances from famous classical
musicians that was going to be torn down
and in protest at the final performance
the entire audience sat silently in
darkness and refused to leave but to
understand the Spy we got to understand
that the loss of these places like the
loss of a hotel or a famous Concert
House wasn't just about the loss of
those physical locations it was about
what losing those things represented at
the turn of the 20th century in Vienna
the way so I describes it polite Society
wasn't just a nicety it was a philosophy
of life that would finally usher in a
modern era of civilized peace rudeness
is merely the expression of fear people
fear they won't get what they want the
most Dreadful and unattractive person
only needs to be loved and they will
open up like a flower you can see pieces
of Swag in the author character Zero and
Gustav h a successful and respected
author someone who had to flee because
of the destruction of war and finally a
lover of art culture and Society who has
to watch the things they love be
destroyed by fascist Uprising for him
the rise of fascist Germany the
Restriction of freedoms and the
destruction of the city that he loved
represented the loss of a specific
philosophical ideal and way of life I
think we see this in the speech that he
gives at the Penn dinner in New York
during his Exile he's not just
apologizing for specific events he's
apologizing for something that he sees
as a more severe metaphysical or
philosophical loss this whole discussion
relates to my last video where I
introduced the concept of meta-modernism
and you don't have to have seen that
video to appreciate this section but I'm
going to expound on those ideas a little
bit here Wes Anderson I think is a
fantastic example of a meta-modern
director and one of the ways I think we
can see Wes Anderson's meta-modernism
shine is in how he interacts with this
more post-modern sort of attitude that
crops up in some of spig's work in the
meta modernism video I describe how
there's kind of this shift from
modernism to post-modernism in arts and
culture as some of the promises of
modernism begin to sour with the world
wars and other events throughout the
20th century swag in his Memoir of the
world of yesterday describes this
prevailing modernist sentiment that he
experienced growing up in Vienna as
having a kind of religious quality in
its liberal idealism the 19th century
was honestly convinced that it was on
the direct and infallible road to the
best of all possible Worlds the people
at the time scornfully looked down on
earlier epochs with their Wars famines
and revolutions as periods when mankind
had not yet come of age and was
insufficiently enlightened now however
it was a mere matter of decades before
they finally saw an end to violence and
evil and in those days this faith in
uninterrupted inexorable progress truly
had the force of a religion people
believed in progress more than in the
Bible and its gospel message seemed
incontestably proven by new miracles of
science and technology that were
revealed daily
this was the feeling of optimism that
zweig was watching be destroyed by the
wars and he describes the feeling of
that loss quite viscerally
we long ago ceased believing in the
religion of our fathers their faith in
the Swift and enduring Ascent of
humanity Having learned our cruel
lessons we see their overhasty optimism
as banal in the face of a catastrophe
that with a single blow canceled out a
thousand years of human effort The Grand
Budapest Hotel isn't just about personal
or material loss and the grief of that
loss it's also about the loss of
idealism I think it's maybe easy to see
both Gustav H and swag As a little bit
hopelessly idealist and nostalgic and
the perfect vision they had of society
was never that truly perfect to be frank
I think his world had vanished long
before he ever ended it but I think this
exaggerated kind of nostalgic
representation of the past and that
feeling of loss does tap into something
that a lot of us do experience and I
think a lot of us succumb to a kind of
nostalgia or idealism whether for the
past or the future more than we care to
admit and so it's in this way that I
think the Grand Budapest Hotel takes on
a kind of archetypal representation of
this loss of idealism that we maybe
don't experience in the very extreme
version that someone like Stefan's feig
experienced but which we inevitably
experience as part of our everyday lives
and I think these losses that are in the
past have more ongoing relevance to our
lives than we might think stand clear
please stand clear everyone listen to
this contact
that's the sound of a German bomb from
World War II exploding during the
production of Fantastic Mr Fox in London
an unexploded bomb from the blitz was
found in a canal next to the Production
Studio production had to be shut down
for a few days so that the bomb could be
safely detonated and when it was Wes
Anderson and the crew recorded the sound
and then ended up using it in Fantastic
Mr Fox you might not be living in Vienna
in the 1900s watching it be destroyed by
war or the concierge of a grand hotel
watching it be stomped by fascist goons
you might not be a war Refugee losing
your young life to an absurd little
disease but you do live in a world that
is still tangibly grappling with the
loss and Fallout from major Wars that
were happening only a few Generations
ago even as we continue to deal with our
own loss and change in 2023 cultural
optimism has been on a decline for what
feels like about a decade for a lot of
reasons and I think the fact that the
Grand Budapest Hotel speaks to those
feelings and came out in 2014 is part of
its success grief is often a recognition
of Something Beautiful being taken from
us without any beauty or goodness there
is no sadness in the loss of that thing
this is why the movie's Beauty goes hand
in hand with its discussion of grief and
loss that discussion wouldn't be as
powerful if it didn't portray something
being lost so beautifully
in this way it mirrors another film that
I love about the second world war a
hidden life
[Music]
the way Terence Malik captures in this
movie The absolutely stunning beauty of
the Austrian Alps with a kind of idyllic
Perfection sets up the pure horror of
that ideal being destroyed by the war
are we stopping at a barley field again
foreign
these black uniforms very drab but
there's one more ingredient to this
movie and how it handles these themes we
all deal with loss or grief In Our
Lifetime and when we lose things it
hurts and a lot of times as humans as
people we don't feel comfortable talking
about our pain our grief or our hurt and
so we kind of have this tendency to bury
that pain in stories and stories are
also a way we try to capture and hold on
to what was lost in the past and bring
it into the future in the end spig's
Exile was too much for him to bear
but Anderson brings a meta-modernist
view to the despair of Spike's life the
film begins and ends with a monument to
the author not zweig explicitly but
almost to the concept itself because
stories are one way what is lost can
live on just as Mustafa maintains the
hotel in memory of Agatha we can
maintain some connection to a past we've
lost through storytelling when we
understand that the world we live in is
one of constant and inevitable change
and that change almost always comes with
a sense of loss and that we're grappling
with the Echoes and residues of losses
in our past even as we deal with losses
in our present and when we understand
that stories and storytellers are ways
of trying to keep and maintain the
things we've lost even while they're
painful reminders of what we've lost at
the same time
then we begin to understand the hidden
beauty of the Grand Budapest Hotel
when doing research about Wes Anderson's
films one of the things that I
constantly come across is that for an
American director he's been incredibly
and deeply influenced by all kinds of
international filmmaking when he talks
about his favorite films they're almost
always movies from France India Japan
Germany or other places all over the
globe one of the best places that you
can watch International Cinema is with
my sponsor for this video mubi mubi is
an online hand curated streaming service
with exceptional films from all around
the world they're constantly adding
films all the time with an explanation
of why it's worth your time so it's a
great place to find new and interesting
stuff to watch that you can't find
anywhere else I also want to mention
their podcast which is a great resource
for learning more about the behind the
scenes of filmmaking their third season
is called the needle on the record and
it covers the use of music and film and
famous needle drops it talk about movies
like 2001 A Space Odyssey and Donnie
Darko you can check that out wherever
you get your podcasts go to movie.com
thomasflight to get an extended 30-day
free trial of mubi to start exploring
wonderful International and Classic
Cinema today
mubi.com thomasflight or click the link
in the description below for your 30-day
free trial of mubi thanks again to mubi
for sponsoring this video
[Music]
thank you